did you enjoy if you look back do you
think you really loved working on
Smallville was it something that you go
you know this was
a many years of my life that I I spent
on this show and playing this character
it's probably one of the most well-known
characters you played right yeah I loved
it I loved it you loved it and then you
know then then seven I was gone and then
9 and 10 yeah they made him just a
villain the the writers were they didn't
I was so I was so excited that when they
said an alternate universe that they
were going to come up with some great
stuff but they just played out
andout
stereotypical villains so you didn't
like that no did you tell
them what you say yeah they it was
beyond them they had yeah there was no
imagination in that yeah alternate
universe yeah well at least she had
seven good years yeah remember you
weren't I had seven Great years I really
were I had a ball it's the longest I've
ever played one part what was the second
Brimstone oh they pulled the plug so
fast on that show really yeah well what
was the second long what other shows
were you on for long this was the
longest because mostly you were filming
and theater I was what mostly you did
film in theater so you didn't do a lot
of like TV uh Series where you were
regular you played Parts like you were
in Law and Order right done many many
parts but I've never spent seven years
with the same character same character
so it was and it was wonderful cuz they
were writing good stuff until nine and
came yeah that's why I left in seven
when Allan miles left and you know
Kristen was leaving uh John Schneider
was already dead I'd already killed you
I'm like there's nothing left for me
there's nothing left for Lex to do here
you know he doesn't have this antagonist
anymore he doesn't have the antagonist
of John Schneider's character who always
had a thing for Lex it was just sort
of I need to move on I need to move on
and you moved and it was funny because I
remember they um the president of the
studio took me to dinner and
said what will make you stay for another
three years I said
nothing and he was so insulted goes look
at Julianne
margaris I go what what about her well
what has she done since ER or whatever
it was and I go and now fast forward she
did The Good Wife and got Awards and is
making so much money but he was just you
know doing using whatever tactic he he
could to get me to stay and then I said
well you know just make me an
offer and they offered me the same money
not a die more is that how you get
somebody to come back for three years
you just say hey you're mowing my lawn
right I know you want to mow someone
else's lawn but you know if you mow my
lawn for three more years I'm going to
give you the same money I don't know if
it's the best analogy but you get what
I'm saying but uh yeah I said no I said
no on that